buenas tardes el caso se remonta a abril
de este año cuando el ex comandante
general del ejército josé vizcarra
denunció haber recibido presiones del ex
secretario presidencial bruno pacheco y
del ex ministro de defensa a walter
ayala para ascender irregularmente
algunos oficiales del ejército tras una
supuesta orden del presidente pedro casi
o el mandatario ha sido citado por la
fiscalía en una investigación que él ha
abierto por la administración pública y
tráfico de influencias junto a nueve
implicados entre quienes se encuentra el
empresario samir vida ver las cosas se
complican para casi o porque es amigo y
haber reacio excarcelado para
convertirse en testigo protegido de la
justicia peruana y se espera que en las
próximas horas vía verde entrega la
fiscalía audios y otras pruebas que
comprometerían seriamente al presidente
de perú francisco puede explicarnos
también el proceso en el que está
envuelta la esposa de pedro castillo
mira paredes primera dama del perú y
repitió alrededor de una escena a veces
ante la comisión de la fiscalización del
parlamento que no declarara por
recomendación de su abogado esta actitud
de la primera dama en lugar de
esclarecer las denuncias que tiene por
tráfico de influencias generó más dudas
entre los legisladores para muchos
congresistas la primera dama de perú se
niega a declarar por recomendación de su
defensa que quiere evitar que ella entre
en contradicciones en la investigación
que le sigue la fiscalía luego que una
empresa constructora ganara una
licitación por más de un millón de
dólares para la construcción de una obra
luego de reunirse en palacio de gobierno
con la primera dama y la hermana de ésta